john s'excuser en soute joli point de
vue dans un peu spéciale alors si vous
voyez que mes cheveux vous inquiétez pas
c'est normal c'est qu'on va couper les
jambes on vous inquiétez pas ceci était
une blague d'ailleurs totalement d'aze
non plus sérieusement si aujourd'hui je
fais cette vidéo c'est pour vous
annoncer que j'ai participé à une
nouvelle parodie cette fois en compagnie
de darnétal alors bon c'était un truc un
peu spéciale douanes tu me suis pris une
gifle a entre autres ou alors si tu
cuisines et voici que là ça me change
d'ailleurs d'habitude et alors que je
suis a dit je vais pas vraiment un
combattant on est en fait j'ai dû faire
une pizza avec marc ouimet débat avec
mam avec ma bouche de pervers et doit la
maca salaire sous couleur ni tête à
pizza mahal lettres à des minorités
j'ai effectivement tu faire cette vie
avec ma bouche alors qu'on s'était un
peu dégueulasse et un peu horrible
surtout très très beau métier très
positif même au moins je m'en suis sorti
vivant d'autre part vous êtes sur mandat
pour les résultats du concours
et bien je peux les avoir juste là en
regardant la description normalement les
adresses mails sont marquées des
gagnants donc ceux qui ont gagné l'un
des troisièmes à remédier à ce qu'ils
ont gagné une des deux consoles donc
normalement vous avez dû recevoir un
mail si tout s'est bien passé
d'autre part vous êtes voir sur facebook
et twitter j'ai posté une photo avec mon
frère on porte des t-shirts qu'on a fait
nous mêmes alors déjà comment l'idée
nous est venue un bond à table ou
t-shirts non aller
d'ailleurs quand tu attends acolytes
c'était toujours un peu impatient mais
alors je peux vous dire que celui-là
qu'on l'a reçue on était vraiment un
taquet c'est une fois encore boulot et
je te rappeler non choisie on a sauté la
clôture dans l'herbe non non non non
rien à faire achète toi la vitre ce soir
je pense
alors on va faire de staouéli un mario
un swing asie de call of duty et les
falcons
alors suite aux photos que j'ai posté
sur facebook et sur twitter vous avez
été vraiment nombreux à me dire [ __ ]
est-ce qu'ils sont disponibles quelque
part comme on peut en avoir et ou alors
ils sont désormais disponibles sur ce
prêcheur donc le lien est dans la
description alors vous pouvez cliquer
sur ma tête maintenant à lézinnes et si
ça vous intéresse pas on s'en bat les
couilles on s'en tamponne le coquillard
à quel jeu perd projet derrière quoi
maintenant quel mauvais et voilà bref
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui les douze en
tout cas vous pouvez passer voir le
nouvel épisode tomb raider qui est sorti
là d'ailleurs maintenant ce sera un
épisode de murder chaque mercredi et
dimanche à 16 heures en force veulent
toujours plus d'aventurés avec jaws
monde pis